que ser eficientemente el cargo de
presidenta de la República luego de un
tsunami político en Perú Dina ercilia
boluarte zegarra se convirtió en la
primera mujer en la historia de ese país
en juramentar como presidenta luego de
la destitución de Pedro castillo
proveniente del departamento de Apurímac
la política de 60 años aseguró que
defenderá la soberanía nacional y que
cumplirá con la Constitución durante su
primer discurso ante el congreso
legislativo
me comprometo ante el país a luchar
porque los nadies los excluidos los
ajenos tengan la oportunidad y el acceso
que históricamente se les ha negado que
viva el Perú Muchas gracias
la nueva mandataria de Perú es abogada
de profesión tiene una larga carrera
política y hasta este 7 de diciembre se
desempeñó como vicepresidenta y titular
del Ministerio de desarrollo e inclusión
social Pero también estuvo en la mira de
la oposición luego de ser investigada
por tráfico de influencias y corrupción
Aunque su caso fue archivado esta misma
semana por ahora se espera que buluarte
esté al mando hasta el 28 de julio de
2026 fin del actual mandato sin embargo
su permanencia dependerá de su relación
con el parlamento y la posición liderada
por la derecha de keiko fujimori quien
dio la bienvenida a la nueva presidenta
saludo la juramentación de Dina boluarte
como primera presidenta del Perú deseo
que su gestión se cumpla en respeto a la
institucionalidad democrática separación
de poderes y por el desarrollo de
nuestro país para ello podrá contar con
el apoyo y respaldo de fuerza popular
durante su ceremonia de juramentación
boluarte pidió un plazo para lograr una
tregua entre los diferentes actores
políticos y llamó a que se abran los
canales de diálogo para acabar de una
vez por todas con la crisis política de
Perú